share
exchange
communicate
after several years inventing solutions
for the future accelerating fiber
deployment making fiber robust and
reliable
we are creating a resilient link
a link that you can count on when all
else fails a link that unites us and
makes us grow a link that allows us to
move forwards together to continue to
treat
to imagine
and to innovate
to continue to meet and to come together
we have overcome so many challenges to
allow everyone
everything everywhere
to stay connected and we will go further
to make fiber more accessible more
widespread today more than ever
high-speed connectivity is a must for
the european economy to thrive we have
worked hard and accomplished much
together but there are further
challenges to come revolutions in
collaboration and health home office and
remote working 5g and fiber convergence
in-home broadband experience smart
cities and new applications
today we are making great strides in
realizing the connectivity of the
future we are rolling out a sustainable
technology for the planet and future
generations
a technology with endless potential and
possibilities adapted for the world of
tomorrow a responsible technology and an
essential technology
for you
us
everyone
building together greater links more
powerful connections more robust
networks for today and tomorrow
our mission is to connect the future and
for this we need all of you
are you
joining us
welcome to the ftdh conference 2022